ces regards ces visages comme l'écho
d'une époque passée d'une époque où la
photographie ne s'improvisait pas ses
portraits de curti nhien du début du
xxème siècle ont inspiré les habitants
d'aujourd'hui a créé une exposition qui
leur sera dédié
tout a commencé par un hasard derrière
cette devanture bleue frédérick baron a
découvert un trésor
je venais d'acheter la crêperie j'étais
en train de débarrasser joue le placard
de vitrines et puis je gratte gravats up
dessous je trouve les plaques
photographiques et c'est comme ça que
tout a commencé
ces vieilles photos sur verts remontent
à l'époque où la maison était un atelier
de photographes tu à peine exhumé
frédérick baron a décidé de les exposer
une initiative rapidement suivi par
cinquante passionnés et parmi eux pascal
cronje c'est lui qui a resterait les
images je suis parti sur une plaque
photographique ensuite de les scanner et
je travaillais numériquement de façon à
arriver à une couleur finale du du
studio qu'on pourrait l'imaginer en 1900
alors ça fait quoi de restaurer bah
c'est complètement magique on a
l'impression de vivre vivre l'instant on
recrée un décor qui n'existait pas à
l'appel de frédéric même les habitants
de courtenay se sont pris au jeu
photos et documents d'époque ont afflué
par dizaines comme si on devenait
dépositaire d'une mémoire et quand
peut-être qu'on savait quoi en faire ça
vous a surpris
je suis toujours surpris évidemment que
ça m'a surpris c'est beau c'est super
beau l'exposition sera prête pour le 13
mars date de son ouverture
pascal et frédéric vous attend de pied
ferme
[Musique]